my name is Andrew and I will be talking
tonight about the automotive industry
and data science in it working gia crate
so as my presentation was shortened a
little bit I have a little proposition
for you
my presentation consists of basically
two parts in the first part we will look
at the automotive industry as a whole
about we'll look at some new
technologies etc I will shorten this
part because the second part is a real
data science project within the
automotive industry it will be probably
something you have never ever seen
before so I'll try to walk you through
it very slowly explain like what's on
the slides but this is the presentation
that the management received so we
should be able to gather to come to a
conclusion and to see like how these
projects are made because most of the
time people come to me and say ok I have
this great idea will we can use like the
new neural networks to process some
images and to identify for example
defects in some car parts and they're
like okay let's do this but this is just
one small part of the whole package we
deliver so I wanted to stress that so
does it sound good to you ok ok so a
little context about me I have been
working as a data scientist for the past
six years I specialize in automotive
industry or in manufacturing in general
however as I currently work in a company
called Trask solutions and Trask works
like 80 percent with financial services
and or finite veinte
basically and 20 percent with automotive
shifting a little bit last but not least
the most important part I love Python I
basically do like 70% of my work in this
language the dress the 20% is SAS which
is really established in
in the banking industry and ten percents
are you know just little experiments
some front-end stuff which I hopefully
can do with - in the second part so I'm
I'm thinking I will learn something new
so but before we begin I have a few
questions for you just to keep it a
little bit interactive so do we have
here anyone who has never ever in their
entire life being in a car like never
ever okay I thought so so who here uses
a car let's say from time to time you
want to make a trip to kutna hora which
I highly recommend by the way you take a
car you go so hands up okay a lot of
people who here uses cars regularly so
on a daily basis you drive to work etc
okay some people with children as well
because those are mostly the ones who
here loves cars do we have any car
enthusiasts okay so let's great so
irrespective of your relationship to
cars the these vehicles have become an
integral part of our lives
they have really transformed how we
cover short and medium distances and in
the car industry there are a lot of
buzzwords and my approach to this
presentation was to give you a little
bit of a realistic look about the car
industry and about what it means and how
it operates and just look a little bit
behind those buzzwords so first let's
cover a little bit about the future of
cars the future of color cars is told to
be XE which means e stands for
electrified by 2030 we estimate that 55
percent of new car sales will come from
a fully electric vehicles a means
autonomous so by 2030 we estimate that
about 40% of our kilometres will be
covered by the VA
autonomously the X C so the C stands for
connected so cars will talk to each
other s means shared and Y means updated
yearly so the idea here is that we will
build a car that is full on spec and you
will purchase some parts of it so if I
have my key and I will put it into
ignition and I have bought massage seats
for example then I can use them and if
you have bought for example Google Maps
then if you put your key in the ignition
then you will have Google Maps in in in
the system so that's about the future
I'll need to okay five minutes so let's
keep this part however many new
technologies are available as of today
are in production cars and there are
government approved I have chosen just
one to give you a little example this
work so these are called dynamic matrix
headlights they consist of 1 million
pixels so these these images are
projected by our headlights this is by
the way a production car it's fully
electric it's manufactured by OD so just
so there's actually a sensor in the
front bumper which estimates if you're
in the front of if you are in front of a
wall or if there's no wall so if there's
no wall it's projected on the ground so
you have the customization options which
are really nice so if you have the money
you can buy this car right now I don't
actually so that's a problem but
hopefully one day but this is just the
tip of the iceberg
there are many new technologies coming
and the future is exciting yeah you have
like I don't know five options this one
is called origami by the way
so what can we use this for for example
this technology if it detects you're on
the highway it illuminates your lane and
I don't know if it if it can be seen in
the video but there are like small black
arrows in in the light so that you
subconsciously stay in the middle of
your line so it is scientifically proven
that if they put these little arrows
there that you drive like more in the
middle of the lane so this is the vision
again I'm picking Audi here but it
doesn't really matter that cars will
communicate with each other and they use
for example these headlights so also if
this car is behind you it can it can use
its high beams to illuminate everything
around you but it uses a cone of light
not to dazzle you so these are
technologies of the future which are
available right now ok a little bit
about the automotive industry in in the
Czech Republic some little facts so in
2018 more than 1.4 million cars were
produced in the Czech Republic which
means that we are in the 5th place in
the Europe the first one is of course
Germany which produces about 8 million
cars the position of the automotive
industry in the Czech industry is very
important I just realized I have my
presentation right there so I can look
there it's very important because like
one-quarter of the whole industry is in
the form of the car manufacturing so you
can view it as so for example if we take
everything that's being produced in the
Czech Republic like one quarter of the
value will be cars ok so the car
industry contributes 9% of the GDP
it employs more than 160,000 people
directly and there are many more
indirectly for example logistic services
and it involves more than 800 companies
okay the most important factor in the
car industry are actually not the car
manufacturers Skoda Hyundai or TPC a
themselves but there are suppliers which
create this really intricate network of
connections I have a question does
anyone recognize any brand but in the
industry so because Bosch also produces
some toolings and and also washing
machines I think so so does anyone know
at least one and what it produces okay
so a fair amount of people great now a
little question we have time for it so
let's do it like right here
so Skoda employs about 34,000 people
here in the Czech Republic and or
worldwide actually worldwide so there
are 34,000 people working for Skoda
worldwide and now my question is how
many people worldwide are there working
for Bosch for example and I'll give you
like three options less people about the
same and more people so who thinks that
less people are working for Bosch
worldwide as a supplier and bear in mind
they just create like smaller parts for
the cars and their else they sell it to
the car manufacturers so they're smaller
so who here thinks that there are less
people working for Bosch worldwide as a
supplier than for Checotah someone ok
thank you
about the same ok so a few people about
the same and more people ok let's say
substantially more so eight times more
who would say even a time or any times
more yes some people ok some extremists
actually if yeah actually it's true
there are more than 250,000 people
working in the Bosch automotive division
worldwide so this really gives you an
example Bosch has more than 460
factories worldwide so this gives you
really an example of the scale of the
suppliers ok we'll skip this actually
Bosch in the Czech Republic has five
factories the biggest one is in Halawa
it employs about 5000 people and there's
also one in Cheska buyo it's about four
thousand people are working there
they're mostly doing fuel systems and
accelerator pedals etc so if I want to
share one idea in this part with you
then it's that these suppliers are
really the bread and butter of the
industry they they create most of the
value and also they do most of the
research and development and these are
just the biggest companies the biggest
suppliers and even they have their own
suppliers and the suppliers have their
own suppliers so it creates this really
huge network of suppliers basically ok
we're it good on time now to the second
part of my presentation what I'm going
to show you now is a data science
project
within the automotive industry I will
explain each and every slide for you but
but just to give you a little context I
cannot name the company but they produce
parts made from plastic which are about
this big air is flowing through them
that's all I can say and they're housed
within the engine compartment so it's a
it's a supplier with about 1000 people
so it's a medium-sized factory producing
plastic parts and
our objective here was that there was
problem with waste so if the product the
plastic part has some defect or bad
color or whatever it's considered to be
waste and it needs to be handled
separately so what we did and when we
started with the project was that we
wanted to really evaluate the statement
the hypothesis was okay there was more
waste coming to the system and I will
explain this class a graph really
quickly the blue line you see there is
separated waste so if the weight is
created you can separate the plastic
parts and then you get money for it but
if you keep it all together there are
more oily parts together and the waste
is considered to be contaminated which
are the red bars and you need also you
need to pay for the contaminated waste
so the idea is separate as much as you
can and create the least amount of waste
you can so what we can see here I don't
know if my cursor is is there a way I
can so what we can see here this is the
part where we started basically in
October there was a huge program to
increase the production of plastic parts
and as you can see the waste raised
substantially and raised more than the
production rose so there was a problem
so we had confirmed the hypothesis but
really the waste went up and this the
unfortunate part was that even that not
just only the separated waste went up
but also the contaminated one so the
company was giving a lot of money to get
rid of this waste so where's the data
science in this part you asked me well
there so there was a lot of data mining
because they have four independent
information systems so we need to
connect to each system some of them are
abort some of them were coded by the
brother of the guy who was head of the
IT so there was no documentation you
didn't know like what to do so we needed
to get it everything together by the way
the whole software I will talk about was
written in Python it uses Jango as a bap
server so everything was fighting ready
okay so guys do you follow me like is
anyone lost at this point we're okay
we're cool okay now if you can tell that
the information system doesn't give you
enough information then you really need
to go to the place and just watch the
physical flow of the material just
explain this slide really quickly what
you see in the blue boxes is the basic
process so we've produced apart you
assemble more parts together by hand or
by machine every part is 100% quality
control so every part needs to be
inspected
then it gets fair house then it gets
loaded on a truck and sent to a customer
what's important on this slide is that
waste can be created at 14 different
places and it all gets together at a
sorting place so we have absolutely no
idea what's the source of this waste so
that's the most important thing on this
slide so what we tried to do okay there
were some process mapping done so that
was the data science part I will explain
it later a bit so what we try to do we
took the information systems and we said
okay we know how many products we
produce the question is if we know on
average the weights of different
products like how many ways can we
get from the system so how many ways is
actually in the system is recorded in
the system so we took the 14 different
parts by the way a funny thing here is
that I was wagered that I cannot put a a
picture of a human experiment in the
presentations and actually I won because
I did I cannot see my cursor but
actually the material degradation
there's a little picture gram of poop so
yeah I won but this is really important
in the project because you're working
with real people and they need to see
that you have a sense of humor and then
you can URL normal human being you're
not just an external consultant doing
some data science stuff there so it was
really important so what we did here we
a grated all the data and found out that
from the 52 tons that were reported by
the waste system only a 33 are recorded
in the information system so waste is is
gone somewhere we don't know where so
basically this slide rate reiterates the
idea that we needed to that 34 percent
of our waste was just gone
we didn't know where it was the data
science part in this was for example
there were about like four waves of
people really recording in the
information system and some products had
their weights associated with them and
some did not so for example we created a
simple machine learning model it was a
hg booster aggressor which had about 30
features and from the parts we did not
know the weight of it estimated the
weight of the parts so there was a lot
of machine learning actually in the
background
okay so if our information system is
really in a state which can be called
catastrophical what can we do about it
because we need to control the weight we
need to know how much waste are we
actually producing there are basically
two approaches to this problem the first
one is called top-down so we shut the
factory down and you clean all the
systems and you begin anew as you can
suspect this was not the preferred
solution so we went something which we
went with something we just called
bottom-up and this means that there are
only two ways for the product to leave
the factory either it is a good product
and it's being shipped to a customer or
it is a not good product and it is it
ends up in waste there are not many more
ways so if we control the customer and
the customer is easy to control or easy
to to talk to because if you send him
bad products he will make a complaint
and if we have also the waste process
under control then you can safely like
start to really uncover where the waste
is going from the system is anyone lost
at this point like are we ok great ok so
we started with the bottom-up approach
so control waste report waste every day
so daily waste handling so we devised a
little simple plan the first step was
just to start sorting because you need
to stop the bleeding first and having so
much contaminated waste with really one
of the objectives of the project the
second part was weight tracking because
we estimated most of the weights so we
wanted to have an idea like how much
weight and how much
waste is created by each production line
the third one was source tracking so we
wanted to know like where this waste
comes from and which products are really
the factors and the fourth the last one
where optimizations so there was a
simple systems system coded in in Python
as I mentioned it aggregates all the
data there were about four web
interfaces many people interacted with
the system so the reports were
absolutely automatic and just explained
this slide this is our daily report that
we started to produce and you can click
actually on on every of these bars and
it will show you like how much of every
product or how much of every type of
waste is there so finally we have some
data ok so last but not least these are
the results of the project in May so as
you can see before we had information
about the waste just after 2 months
because the systems were just so slow
and it was calculated based on the
invoice of the contractor which was
taking the waste from us with our system
we had it basically real time like most
of it was calculated in batches each
hour so after each and every shift we
could say ok these products were really
problematic and they need to be taken
care of and these products were good and
as you can see and we also shifted the
the blue bar a red bar ratio there was
more than 11 10 tons more separated
waste which amounts up to about like six
thousand and four hundred euros monthly
which is about sixty four thousand and
it's about seventy-five thousand euro
yearly which is not that much actually
for these types of projects if I did
something with production or actually
influence the production line directly I
would like something in the realm of
five times to 10 times more just to be a
successful project but this was
something that the company really needed
so let's say the money was not that hot
but it was pretty nice
so just some key takeaways from the
project or let's say key lessons if
you're doing a data science or an m/l
project in in the industry you really
need to possess deep technical knowledge
of the production processes and there's
one of the biggest problems with with
new startups trying to get into the
automotive industry as a whole also
machine learning or data science needs
to be packaged as as an entire deal and
as an enabler of value so you use these
models to bring the company the money
the the management actually doesn't care
if it's written Python if you do or
actually what kind of machine learning
it uses the only thing they're really
looking forward to or looking at is the
money that they that the service brings
to them and this is like one of the set
realities of the job so integration and
project management is just as important
as the algorithms you really need to get
the project team on board so that was
the little poop thingy and there you saw
yeah it's it's a small part but it's
really important just to get all the
people on board because those people
will use your system after you are gone
from the factory and for last but not
least projects cannot be handled
remotely like mostly
some companies do like 40% remotely but
what I like to do is really to spend
time with the people in the factory and
to be there so that's all from my part
if we have any questions I hope this was
beneficial to you